it's been nearly four months since
sharon osborne was fired from
the talk osborne's co-hosts were furious
that she defended her friend pierce
morgan from accusations of racism
after he criticized meghan markle must
be racist
and then they threw her under the bus
painting her as a racist
during a segment on the show in a
classic ambush but
now thanks to some leaked hot mic audio
obtained by the daily mail
we know that their outrage was just tv
magic
i know you're upset i know it was
terrible but i just hope that
once this blows over once we that you
know
cheryl is your friend she really is
cheryl and i are held to
a different standard by black
people and people of color out there who
expect
us to say something about every
racist anything similar and it puts us
in such a [ __ ] up position
that even if we don't have the
information if we don't even really care
if we don't really want to engage
it feels like a spotlight is on us you
know
and and so it's like i think
that cheryl was trying to navigate that
line
you know spotlight was on us have to
throw him under the bus here now with
reaction
host of water's world author of the now
number one new york times best-selling
book
how i saved the world jesse waters jesse
congrats thank you very much very
sincerely that's a huge thing
considering they would love
any anything to keep you if i didn't get
number one
i would have told myself they rigged it
against me which of course they would of
course been true
of course but look at this this clip how
revealing is it
we don't we don't even if we don't care
even if we don't know anything
we have to we have to say it's racist
it's a takedown job you know when you're
very successful people want to take you
out they want to take you out pete
you see it all the time they're coming
for you it's pretty obvious
she was the only famous person on that
show i don't even know any of those
other women's names so
the producers were involved producers
you can't trust them i used to be a
producer terrible people
so what did she say actually she said
piers morgan
called meghan markle a bad word or
something she said he's not racist
they say he is racist she says give me
an example they couldn't give her an
example
and then she gets cancelled so ozzy
osbourne the husband's got to be
thinking wait i better head off a bat
i worship the devil and i peed on the
alamo and you're getting canceled for
that
that's crazy they were more than and
here's the other thing we got one more
piece of sound because behind the scenes
they admitted even further we don't even
care about this stuff
that much listen i'm not a dni expert
i do i didn't know i was gonna come on
here and be the no
i don't know how to do that actually
neither do i
i'm just a old woman
that has a lot of stories next i don't
okay if you're an alien are you a nice
alien
they come sit down i mean the mob had to
be fed
that's what it comes down to you gotta
feed the mob the mob's hungry and i
don't even buy that
that's someone like oh i got you fired
you know i didn't really mean to
sorry i didn't really know what i was
doing up there they knew exactly what
they're doing
they throw these racial hand grenades at
people they don't like and they just
blow them up for power
yep i mean we're going to actually care
we are the most likable people on
television
but people lob hand grenades at us all
the time because they hate us but if
they got to know us pete
they would love us that's true having
gotten to know you
it's mixed but mostly good
mostly good some people i'll take it
mostly peaceful mostly
peaceful i'll take jesse waters real
quick the book tell us about it why it's
so successful so it's a comedy piece but
it's also interesting because there is
political analysis in it these are all
my
travels throughout the country san
francisco nude beaches
quizzing people on the beach and i found
out what makes liberals tick and it's
their insecurities we describe
the psychological warfare that they've
done to themselves
and they're projecting on the rest of
the country and you've heard these
stories about
the trump and i having dinner and going
on air force one these are hilarious
but you will be fed a lot of insight but
also a lot of laughs i guarantee you
this book
will make you live longer pete really
because laughter makes you live longer
okay good and that is the scientific
fact that i think so
indisputable indus follow
a lot of people are saying i agree jesse
congrats thank you thanks for being here
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else